so what you gonna do for the hundred
video I don't know any good ideas in the
comments a couple people want a great
scientist list done this guy Cameron
wants a top ten tops of tents list done
hey it looks like you just passed ten
thousand subscribers - I've got it
hey crazies how many of you have heard
of an order of magnitude there is a nice
simple way to get what we call ballpark
estimates which is just a
baseball-reference leftover from the
1960s actually there is evidence of
abuse
early if thank you forty five it just
wasn't a widespread use until the
nineteen sixties whatever metaphorically
speaking you don't need to know exactly
where the base ball ended up sometimes
you only need to know if it's in the
ballpark or outside it what does this
have to do with the hundredth video
everything no don't leave it'll be okay
come back let's start with some very
basic stuff our decimal number system is
based on tens probably because we have
10 digits on our hands I mean decimal
literally means of tens mathematically
it just means we have ten single-digit
numbers 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and 9
everybody still with me ok good once we
get to 10 we have to add an extra digit
and that extra digit has to count
through our single-digit numbers we
don't get to add a third digit until 100
in other words we have a ones place in a
tens place and a hundreds place in a
thousands place and so on but kind of
like milestones for our decimal number
system you know those signs on roads
that mark distance I seem to be using a
lot of metaphors in this video anyway
all those number places are powers of 10
10 to the 0 10 to the 1 10 to the 2 10
to the 3 and so on and the power number
is called an order of magnitude this is
the hundredth video on this channel
which is order of magnitude to this
channel also hit 10,000 subscribers
which is order of magnitude for two
different orders of magnitude at the
same time are you just gonna geek out
about numbers for five minutes
okay okay I'll get to the point as it
turns out we can say every number has an
order of magnitude think of it like it's
rerouting its whatever power
10 is closest to that number but the
word closest doesn't always mean what
you think it means
with normal rounding 5 is the halfway
mark er anything from say 1.0 to just
under 1.5 rounds down to 1 and anything
from say 1.5 2 2.0 rounds up to 2 so you
would expect orders of magnitude to work
the same way anything from 1 to 5 rounds
down to 1 and anything from 5 to 10
rounds up to 10 but you'd be wrong
ok now prepare yourselves for the next
bit we're going to use something you
probably thought you'd never see again
logs no no logs isn't logarithms Oh to
find an order of magnitude you first
take the common log of that number
that's the log base 10 because we're
looking for powers of 10 then you round
the result like normal but this makes
orders of magnitude a little weird
rounding like this moves the halfway
mark er from half of 10 down to root 10
or from 5 down to a little over 3 which
skews toward rounding up by that
reasoning my height is 10 feet or 1
meter my weight is a hundred pounds my
mass is 100 kilograms my age is a
hundred years there are 10 billion
people living on the planet
our next subscriber goal is a hundred
thousand which by orders of magnitude we
technically achieve at thirty one
thousand six hundred and twenty-three
it's crazy but it gives us really easy
numbers to work with let's say we wanted
to estimate how much it would cost to
upgrade all US homes to be
energy-efficient the 2010 census says
there were about 309 million people
living in the u.s. 3.09 is just shy of
Route 10 so we round down to a hundred
million there is an average of two point
six people per household which rounds
down to one only 65% of homes are owned
which Browns up to one hundred percent
or one by orders of magnitude
energy-efficient upgrades cost ten
thousand dollars one hundred million
times one times one times ten thousand
dollars is one trillion dollars and for
comparison that's the same order of
magnitude as the 2008 bank bailout
usually any rounding up of one number is
balanced by the rounding down of another
so you get pretty close estimates really
fast
Enrico Fermi was known for being
impressively good at this during the
first atomic bomb test he estimated the
blast yield to the correct order of
magnitude using ripped up pieces of
paper oh that guy was a genius please
share your thoughts in the comments and
if you're up for the challenge come up
with some of your own order of magnitude
estimates a huge thank you to all 10,000
subscribers for riding this crazy trade
with me Oh a special thanks goes out to
patreon patrons like Nikola who helped
make these videos better and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy in the last video we learn the
truth behind the equals mc-squared
come out response time all right after a
bunch of your comments I realized I
could have been a bit clearer the title
of the video was why doesn't light have
mass the answer is that it actually
might have it depending on how you
define mass when most people hear the
word mass they think of rest mass which
light definitely does not have however
if you're an experimentalist then all
you care about is what you can measure
in that case light does have mass in
every measurable way light can affect
some things gravity and light can give
things momentum when it hits them
because it is the silly thing called
relativistic mass rest mass plus kinetic
mass equals relativistic mass none of
our measuring devices distinguish
between different types of mass to them
mass is just mass anyway I apologize for
the lack of clarity at the end of the
video totally my fault
hindsight is a several if you also
pointed out that light slows down in
materials except you're wrong well again
this depends on your scientific
philosophy say you've got two lasers but
only one passes through a block of glass
that one is definitely going to take
longer to travel the length of the block
so an experimentalist would say the
light is going slower but a theoretical
physicists like myself looks much deeper
a lot is going on with that light inside
the block along the way the photons of
light have to interact with atoms
the light in the block only appears to
slow down it doesn't actually slow down
thanks again to all 10,000 subs and to
everyone who comments there are so many
comments it's getting difficult to
answer them all so to those of you who
answer each other's questions thank you
so much hopefully we can keep this up
I'll see you next time